you
Otacon snake are you okay
I've been down in every fire and I can't
get this door open
which door uh I'm on level 2b snake you
need to go back to level 2a and use the
key card to get in Otacon that room is
filled with poison gas you need the
peripheral crystals perineum crystals
press the select button to view your
items select button what are you talking
about Otakon I'm gonna die here you need
to find the gem of understanding but
akan press r2 to see if you have it ah
snake did I ever tell you the story of
how my father died it's about 25 minutes
long Annika there are too many of them
hi
[Music]
this is my view for melt gear solid one
through four don't worry I won't do that
the whole time
I love the Metal Gear Solid games
they're honestly my favorite games of
all time all four of them I'm not even
going to worry about rating them because
I'd adore them all they're all fantastic
and since you will want to know I can
tell you my orders my favorite is the
first one simply because of nostalgia it
was the first one I ever experienced and
had such a great impact on me that I
like Metal Gear 4 then 2 then 3 but I
loved all of them I mean it's like
rating the original Star Wars trilogy to
me they're all amazing these games
Center on a character named snake Solid
Snake and he's like the ultimate
hardcore guy who has experienced
everything possible and to get into the
plot of his games too much will kind of
overshadow what I'm trying to say and
I'm trying to say is either simply the
best action games ever made in my
opinion in regards to story character
the cutscenes the way it's directed the
music the gameplay the controls
everything about these games is as close
to perfection as video games get when
they put the character of snake on Super
Smash Brothers Brawl for the Nintendo
Wii a lot of gamers were all upset
they're like that's PlayStation Man
don't be doing that but a lot of people
don't know that Metal Gear actually
originated on the NES
and there was a sequel as well on NES
both of those games are a lot of fun - I
love NES see a lot of games today are
overrun with this idea the games can
only be great if it features endless you
know violence killing shooting you know
no no real story that you can be
invested in no Metal Gear Solid is the
prime example of story and video games
that will wrap you up in it and you will
just feel for these characters so much I
actually almost cried during some of
these games the story is so interesting
[Applause]
[Music]
the games are largely based on stealth
missions and it's not really the
objective to engage people in combat the
objective is to get to your place
without having to do that and so that
makes the game really suspenseful too
because I can't tell you how many times
I was like crawling on the ground by
enemies and if I heard this sound but I
would just poop my pants the Metal Gear
games are excellent as you can see from
my opening that my buddy Victor freakin
film critic helped me with their
nostalgic for me they mean a lot to me
first time I beat Metal Gear Solid 1 for
the PlayStation I went back the very
second day and I beat the entire game
again in one day I cannot express how
excellent these games are they're all
different in various ways every single
one has credible storylines they will
all wrap you up in that environment and
they'll show you what games can be games
give me more than just mindless action
stop playing Halo for a second and
appreciate some of the best action games
ever made
[Music]